programmer christian fortune is out in
berlin he's been using foursquare for
three years now the app allows him to
pinpoint his location and discover
nearby hot spots that have registered
with the service by checking in at these
places he can show all his Foursquare
friends where he is i'm a particular fan
of foursquare because it's a wonderful
combination of a social network and a
really smart guide for venues from
restaurants to museums what's more many
cafes and shops offer rewards for
checking in in espresso ambulance this
takes the form of a newbie special every
first-time patron here receives a free
cappuccino but what's in it for the cafe
ran mon if you type espresso ambulance
into a search engine you can see that
we've become pretty well connected with
Foursquare users have uploaded tons of
photos of our cafe and that's good
advertising for us with the pore-water
thorns
another perk whoever frequents a
location the most is crowned the virtual
mayor of that venue Christian Burton has
become mayor of no less than 11 places
as good songs on I'm happy about being
mayor of my favorite Italian restaurant
or Berlin Central Station which I used
to commute to of course I'm aware that
it's nothing earth-shattering it's just
an icon on a nap I'm not willing to take
big detours but sometimes I'll take a
different route on the city train to
check in somewhere taken zoo lubish
title yah discussions I'm now we're off
to San Francisco where Holger Luda from
Germany is making his way to the
Foursquare offices it's his job to tap
into new markets the social network has
several headquarters and has garnered
over 30 million members worldwide
Foursquare wants to become more than
just a virtual meeting place for friends
buzz yield often checking based on the
check-in data or what we call the social
signal we can generate local
recommendations that are completely
tailored to you such as shops
restaurants bars and so on in your
facility engineer and fear the company
is financed by various venture capital
firms it's not yet listed on the stock
exchange Foursquare users around the
world have checked in more than three
billion times to date creating a huge
collection of data on their own
movements
but foursquare comes with clear privacy
settings not all of the information is
passed on this is 50 state it's very
important that the client determines
exactly how much of their data is shared
with a local provider so for example
it's a bit like walking into a shop for
the first time after a few months and
the shopkeeper already has my name and
can perhaps see the first letter of my
surname which last iniesta washed and
mine is not mom's back to Berlin
Christian bitching has checked into more
than 7,000 places in the last three
years he's fully aware of the risks
that's really checking from realizing of
course I'd never check in at people's
private flats and if I had a job
interview it it seemed weird to check in
at a company maybe it's just something
that you really have to keep in mind as
the Headless Horseman Xia Xia stock in
lewiston harmless complete data
protection is an impossibility on the
web everyone must decide for themselves
how much they wish to reveal
shift says recommendations to recommend